[Musique]
17h27 vous êtes en direct sur bfmtv joe
biden est le 46e président des états
unis ce sont les médias américains qu'il
affirme à l'instant partout dans le pays
des scènes de liesse comme ici à
philadelphie mais aussi new york ou
encore washington
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup mais cas est très très
contents très très joyeux et il n'est
pas le seul ce soit grave problème du
chômage
corentin ses landes peut pas voir votre
sourire derrière votre masque mais on
imagine malgré tout que vous avez un
grand sourire comme nous tous c'est
normal d'avoir un sourire dont ne
voteront pas aux états unis que nous
sommes réalistes suppose être neutre
alors nous sommes neutres
on est content surtout que ça se finisse
dubaï donne peut être élu mais pour
donald trump ça ne change rien il avait
prévenu la veille du scrutin
on va y aller dès que l'élection sera
terminée nos avocats seront prêt prêt à
déclencher sa première option pour
rester président l'abattage jury de
nombreuses procédures sont ouvertes
michigan pennsylvanie géorgie nevada
wyss consigne les tribunaux de chacun de
ces états devront trancher quant à
parfois la discrétion est la meilleure
des solutions avancées furtif
le site
mais c'est ça le problème c'est quand on
fait un truc c'est pas terrible
quelquefois ça peut marcher autre
célébration étonnante celle du musée
madame tussauds de londres où sont
exposés des statues de cire celle de
donald trump vient de changer de costume
elle est désormais d'études une tenue de
golf référence à l'activité que pratique
et donald trump lors de l'annoncé de sa
défaite
le point a fait très fort cette semaine
en décrochant une interview de la star
du moment
une interview exclusive du coronavirus
je vous jure que c'est un véritable
article qui a été publié jours parce
qu'il est quand même très demandé en ce
moment et j'ai l'impression que ça lui
est un petit peu monté à la tête je
voulais un extrait qui êtes-vous
coronavirus je commencerai par dire
modestement que je suis le king le roi
ça a été vraiment publier comme s'il se
prend pour elle vivre mais quelle
goulard
ce jeune homme souhaite rentrer chez lui
en guyane avant de monter à bord de
l'avion
il doit passer un test en qui gène ikke
c'est possible à l'aéroport d'orly
imaginez le logiciel dans lequel nous
sommes aujourd'hui qu'on voit dans un
film au cinéma des gens s'embrasser ou
se toucher ça vient ça vient quelque
chose quasiment d'abstrait c'est dans
cela qu'on est rentrés ils l'ont dit
qu'il fallait dans sa 610 vie bat tous
les gens raisonnables
d'accord il faut plus voir de gens c'est
quand même aussi simple que ça donc on
peut même pas se faire livrer un délit
verrous après 22 heures
comment font les gens qui travaillent
tard est ce que quelqu'un arrêtera la
folie liberticide qui s'est emparée les
décideurs publics
mais c'est vrai ça c'est une bonne
question
elle est donc jamais on fait comment
pour manger c'est en fini tard et qu'on
a plus des libéraux je crois qu'on a une
solution devant nous on va faire cuire
des pâtes logel aujourd'hui
hydroalcoolique le jem le sert à rien ah
bon c'est l'alcool c'est une arme de
destruction massive comme ça que ça veut
dire quand même que l'alcool est donc
plus important que le masque or j'ai
l'impression qu'on nous dit tout le
contraire depuis de vous contredire mais
j'ai l'impression qu'on nous dit tout le
contraire depuis des mois et des mois à
chaussures connaît on fait tous partie
de la tribune et qu'on finit là c'est
sûr oui oui ça nous échappe c'est pour
ça que que nous sommes les cons soumis
des cons finis
voilà maintenant je travaille pas non je
travaille pas depuis mercredi 16h16 à
laquelle j'ai commencé à travailler
gratuitement comme toutes les femmes de
france entre un homme et moi l'écart
salarial est cette année de 15 5%
antalya sophie on est parti pour 39
jours ouvrés de travail gratuit on se
lève et on se casse
vous étiez payer avant goût non à
l'origine du mot travail
la référence c'est
un instrument de torture
premier baiser de cinéma qui avait fait
sept bardot elle m'a fait un détartrage
j'ai trouvé ça génial titre de cette
paire métier fantastique on peut se
faire un petit a cappella énormissime
qu'est ce que c'est ça sert à coups de
on a un coup de chaud dans le cippa sais
pas ce que c'est mais comme si vous me
parliez des merveilles aux socialistes
ou je sais pas quoi
attention attention attention je remet
ça dans le cif est bas alors on est
content d'être là qu'il ya 20 millions
de sangliers en france 1 million
j'en ai jamais vu un de plus ma vie 4
même beaucoup plus trop bien même plus
de 5 de même puisque ça j'en ai je sais
combien de chinois en france 300 milles
mais je crois que j'ai tout vu alors 3
il ya plus de sangliers que de chinois
en france
bientôt on va aller au tabasser les
chinois qui essaient des sangliers
la liberté d'expression je mets ça au
dessus de tous au dessus de tous au
dessus de tout même au risque de sa vie
il faut savoir ce qu'on veut
si on veut mourir à enchaîner on peut
mourir enchaîné oui c'est vrai et on
peut apprendre à fermer sa gueule et
traverser la vie en fermant sa gueule
c'est difficile
très belle soirée à vous et à demain dès
13h
[Musique]
il a fumé la moquette neutralité